I want you to understand the difference
between leverage and an energetic
manipulation okay so get a good grip I'm
going to use a leverage technique so I'm
going to shorten the lever by using my
elbow as the ful point and
uh the uh center of the technique the
poter
articulation is going to be about
manipulating his two his two hands okay
so keep my elbows tight good grip good
tight grip okay and I'm just going
to come into this
grip grip really hard really
hard good two poke your okay with this
bu
motion bring it
up
think about turning here elbow
[Music]
tight then my elbow is still moving him
elbow's still
moving
okay let's
try okay so what you're doing is just uh
you're using this shorter fulcrum
against him it creates an opening right
here in the grip you see it right in the
grip it's where you are
boomp you have this contention
point in the
grip okay some things to notice though
when does he start
falling not till I
enter okay so same that same
Motif he's got balance I'm using
Superior mechanic to get his balance but
I'm still pushing on him you might have
felt that right and that might make you
feel powerful
but the notability of your exertion is
telling you you're not powerful
okay so same I'm not going to worry
about his two hands it doesn't matter
okay so um I'm not trying to turn him
here go ahead and pull pull pull pull
okay same thing doesn't matter
Bo into the
ground front foot
boom
boom boom
Bo I'm going to go around this entire
thing by making his Center go around the
grip that's the difference okay last
time I worked his
grip to go around his Center this time I
make his Center go around the
grip and you'll notice I end up touching
somewhere else so on the first version
Oh my elbow is right on the contact
point
on this version he's going to be up here
also on this version I'm kind of in
front of
him on this version I'm going to be
behind him this what I
want so once I pass this I make his
Center come
around and then I'm going to use this
contact point to make his Center go
[Music]
up
so here I'm trying a mechanical
advantage that's still hard for me cuz
he's bigger much bigger than
me this
one his Center I make his Center go
around the
grip puling puling front foot oh get in
the back make him go around is
here up now this arm is
doing other version like how his back
foot is still back there this version
back qus
forward back quits in the
back back ftch in the front
if you ever feel that foot in the
backx you don't do coo that throws being
counter
okay okay so if you're pushing you're
pushing push boom push boom okay and uh
so your energy is coming in and bouncing
off see okay when you pull it's going to
be the same thing so I'm not sitting
here going like that okay so you pull
pull pull me that way come on get me the
wall me to okay so the same thing you're
going to bounce this time off the top B
and it's going to make you move you see
B makes you move
and then I just keep that incrementally
going so you pull it's going to make you
move boom boom up make you move
up here we're doing the same thing
you're pulling makes you
move
verion keep it on you your lightweight
feels way heavier
on
heut so when you get here don't try to
pick him up bring him around in that
same resistance
boom
boom same thing I just keep
incrementally using
that till I get
your Center over that's what's making my
arm go up you see not me lifting
it
boom boom just lifting it boom boom
there's
leg I'm just
exaggerating you're pulling
good
ground move into the in space you
created do it
again and then I start working this
one when my arm gets high enough is when
his leg Center gets for forward enough
then I can start working this
one when I'm
ready
right that little turn is what brings
that leg up not
this here I did KNE to Center about
there then this shoulder
continues leg
up
okay he so not only is it less uh
straining on me but because I don't have
to overcome that foot and because he's
already falling by the time I enter I
can use my stance now not just for
propulsion I can use my stance for
[Music]
[Applause]
place
okay you see how I'm taking out his base
so even the most athletic person cannot
reposition their faes supp back under
their line of gravity
okay